here's what would happen if we woke up  volcanoes to fight climate change  if you could figure out how to control  and Trigger not one but many volcanic  eruptions worldwide you could be sitting  on a golden ticket to solving our global  warming problems let me explain you'd  need to find a volcano that's ready to  erupt and then you'd need to make it  Blow Sky High you'd want eruptions that  would occur closest to the stratosphere  and you'd want to consider other factors  like air circulation patterns and the  amount of sunlight reflected by the  Earth's surface volcanic eruptions would  decrease global temperatures due to the  particles from the volcanic blast which  would prevent the sun's Rays from  hitting Earth but negative effects would  also occur like rainfall increasing or  decreasing dramatically so it's  definitely possible but there's bound to  be a better solution because